so herzlich wie die leute herkommen zu
einem video in dem wir heute mal die
ganze sache ein bisschen anders machen
werden und zwar sah sich heute zu hause
und hatte ein bisschen zeit wieder
rausgehen haben spazieren gemacht man
habe auf insider mit sehr vielen von
euch geschrieben werden fragen gemacht
haben fragen beantwortet um das thema
kohle und ich merke dass mittlerweile
wie ihr wahrscheinlich auch merkt die
maßnahmen die in deutschland ergriffen
werden relativ drastisch sind was
natürlich darauf schließen lässt dass es
auch notwendig ist diese maßnahme zu
ergreifen und die leute drehen durch in
deutschland größtenteils natürlich
maximal übertrieben und deswegen dachte
ich leute machen wir heute mal ein video
rund um das thema weil auch wenn manche
von euch sich denken wow ich will davon
nichts hören
man muss darüber was hören man muss sich
darüber informieren
ich habe mir viele leute wieder zur
eingezogen weil ich ein bisschen was zu
dem thema noch erzählen dem video wir
testen heute mal wie es heute am 14.3
2020 um circa 15.30 mittags einkaufen zu
gehen weil man von überall aus
deutschland berichtet hat das merkt
eigentlich her sind die sich um die
übertrieben sind herzlich ein keinen
fall aber den sprichwörtlichen sinne
kloppen sich leute um toilettenpapier
und wir jetzt mal drei supermärkte
besuchen aus 30 den preisklassen teuer
normal und günstig und gucken was da
abgeht
wir legen jetzt los so leute machen sie
erst mal auf dem weg zu einem ein natura
das ist der die proaktive quasi eine
preisklasse teuer heute besuchen werden
ich muss noch ein paar sachen vorneweg
sagen beim metzger oder zeitpunkt dafür
und zwar hab ich in den fragen die wir
morgen gestellt habt und den stories der
täter wird morgen auf ins tram übrigens
hat es gezeigt herausgehört dass viele
relativ krasse sachen erlebt haben also
wir haben leute mit asiatischen wurzeln
geschrieben dass sie irgendwie
diskriminiert werden und ich kann sich
das jetzt mal aber
rona oder sowas bezeichnet werden wenn
ich mir einen kopf so kompakt wo sind
wir denn hier
und andere leute die halt begeistert
kann haben es darum und sachen kämpfen
oder aus krankenhäuser klauen und so
leute und deswegen bevor wir jetzt kann
ich da ankommen und mit dem julius leben
eine klare ansprache leute wir müssen
jetzt einfach in diesen zeiten die wir
jetzt gerade durchleben in europa als
europäer und gerade als deutscher
einfach zusammen stehen wir müssen
einfach zusammenstehen und uns
solidarisch zeigen das heißt dass wir
den anderen also die personen um uns rum
als gleichberechtigte mitmenschen
mitbürger hier in deutschland sehen und
das war es einfach wieder so als eine
einheit verstehen heute versteht was ich
meine
wir müssen einfach mehr zusammenhalten
so desinfektionsmittel aus
krankenhäusern klauen geht nicht
in den supermärkten deutlich mehr als
der eigene bedarf ist zu kaufen und zu
haben es dann geht nicht leute zu
diskriminieren weil sie aus asien kommen
und das virus hat auch aus asien kommt
geht nicht so das würde ich mir wünschen
leute für uns dass wir ein bisschen mehr
aufeinander achten mehr zusammenhalten
und ja jetzt geht's los
wie man sieht die kölner innenstadt ist
wie leergefegt die menschen leiden also
selber geisteskranken oder eine sagt
muss man auch sagen ich mache die ganze
sache mit max ein wunderbar versetzte
der hilft aber hat auch schon die ganze
zeit ich bin aber eher kalt ich bin
erkältet
ich bin eher kalt dass ich war zunächst
zu erwarten aber dann bin ich eher kalt
ich bin erkältet und es ist ein sehr
eigenartiges gefühl in diesen tagen
erkältet zu sein weil alle leute gucken
einander ein aussätziger keine sorge
meine symptom entdecken sich in keinster
weise mit dem mit denen von corona
deshalb bin ich unbesorgt aber es ist
ein bisschen crazy wie die leute in
teilweise angucken wenn man hustet
deutsche informiert sich über diesen
thoma und jetzt geht der natur und
gucken wie es der bio elite deutschlands
in der krise geht
[Musik]
irgendwie sind wir sind wir sind selbst
aber was für geile sachen alter komme
hier eine harte haltung erst erster
punkt was stand immer flüssig sei für
sensitive
ja zu recht das ist als als dokument
ihrer wenn deutschland die heile wolle
dass sie fast vergessen
[Musik]
zwieback ist es mal da
die katastrophe sei es gibt einfach
keine titel
er ist echt crazy natur wäre ein zu
planen und sich denken und hat richtig
was gehört zum normalen uhr der insel
sind
italien stürzt du normal nudel komplett
leer und somit hier sind das geht echt
verkaufen es geht hier schon wieder die
latte
frauen lassen als ob sie betrieben von
axel f
wissen was das hier feine frische
blätter flammen werden außer an ostern
bewusst sind da vor sich davor so
richtig harte krise und du kannst eine
haltbare bioziden milch trinken
übrigens wollen jetzt auch nicht nur die
ganzen jobs aber macht es einfach nur
spaß haben auch heutzutage noch walnuss
kerner auch einfach rausgekauft genauso
wie soja und hafer drinks die noch
komplett verdrängen
das überleben es geht weiter ich muss
aber die art und weise der produkte
ausverkauften ein bisschen steigen die
sind bergwiesen sind haus und gelbe
linsen und und 3 ist es auch gott bin
sojadrink seien dafür wird er sich
verbinden reisen sowie das arbeiten
nicht hinterher bin wieso fertigprodukte
new york wenn man schlau wird man sich
halten können denn keiner weizen oder
anders gesagt für das testet gegen clubs
bezieht kann also wie gesagt hast du
darfst nur mit den kasachen rauskriegen
alles anderes verboten ok also ist jetzt
raus ist mal ein natura ich muss sagen
das war alles noch relativ entspannt da
es ist augenscheinlich soll dass die
leute bei alnatura ziemlich hart auf
dinkel produkte ab gehen also quasi
alles waren auch daten noch nicht in der
dinkel version
wenn wir als nicht dinkel produkt
konsumenten oder wenig denken konnte
endlich interessant aber es geht weiter
leute wir gehen weiter zur natur muss
man sagen ist natürlich ultra high preis
ultra teuer
rewe ist auch ein teurer teurer
lebensmittelhändler muss man sagen aber
wir schauen mal wie es da aussieht
könnte mir vorstellen dass da schon ein
bisschen mehr abgeht ist es natürlich
auch sein dass vier allgemein uns hier
so ein bisschen in hannover liebe finden
weil wir halt in der großstadt sind ja
dass die leute hier irgendwie keine
ahnung wo sich denken soja und yoghi
überhaupt nicht sondern gibt uns auch
nicht klar wir müssen wir haben es
einfach nicht da das schon dass man auch
dazu sagen ich glaube dadurch dass zum
beispiel auch mitten in der großstadt
teurer sind und so leben glaube ich in
der großstadt gerade in der mitte der
großstadt wo wir wohnen eher leute die
vielleicht ein bisschen deutlich dunkler
wissen besser qualifiziert sind ein
bisschen optimistischer sind für die
zukunft und deswegen vielleicht weniger
zu hamsterkäufen licon wobei der
parkplatz ist randvoll
weil dazu sollen einfach seine services
kassow hamsterkäufe sind einfach nicht
notwendig also mein austauschschüler
lebt in italien und die sind 19 der
ganzen entwicklung ein ganzes stück
voraus um genau zu sein eine woche und
der meinte so tut mir nur einen gefallen
wenn es in deutschland auch so weit so
weit geht wie bei uns hier dann zeit
nicht so dumm und macht schlangen in den
supermärkten weil das ist nicht nötig
und das daraus können wir glaube ich
lernt also leute man kann wirklich
heutzutage auch in der phase wo es viele
leute gibt diese verschwörungstheorien
verbreiten und so meiner meinung nach
noch sehr gut auf
in deutschen stahl- und die
institutionen im krisenschutz vertrauen
das mache ich zumindest ich vielleicht
macht ja auch jetzt nachdem wir das ziel
gehabt dass es sogar in italien die
vielleicht nicht ganz so gut organisiert
sind wir trotzdem super läuft davon aus
dass bei uns zu sein wird jetzt machen
wir ein blick in den rhein
das ist aber nicht so dass typische
hamster gut ich glaube die leute gehen
wir haben eine andere herangehensweise
die wollen einfach ihr immunsystem ist
total
das
das auch alles
[Musik]
roth da an wo es anfällt
das größte teil eine packung vor kunde
hat in den zwei tagen will muss ich
leider schon erkrankt oder das ist noch
da und vor allem ihre war also wieder
dreht das wirklich schweineteuer
supermarkt würde dass hier leute sind
wie ich auch mehr verdienen vielleicht
bis langfristig sind wir in zukunft das
ist mein lieblingsfach
das wird schon vettel ich glaube aber
dass leute auch ein paar dazu neigen so
nach zu abend die sehen sie wo alle
kochen klopapier und nun das ist richtig
weil ich meine künstler immer so gut ich
kann ja nicht mehr unnötig also ist
kommt das irgendwie ähnlich gut damit
anfangen
[Musik]
krass da ist
komplett bauen
ja
das
keine lohn
aber so wie wir sie aus dem revier und
ich muss sagen es war ein sehr
eindrucksvoller moment da schon also man
hat schon eine ganz andere stimmung
gehabt als bei alnatura da waren
wirklich einige regale ausgeräumt und ja
die leute war ein bisschen hektisch
drauf wir hatten tatsächlich das glück
dass da ein mitarbeiter wird uns
gesprochen hat so rein zufällig ins
gespräch gekommen wäre natürlich hat was
so bei denen gerade abgeht er meinte es
kommen täglich drei lkws die den
supermarkt gefälligst jetzt bis jetzt
und haben bis 24 uhr geöffnet
stimmt es ist viertel nach 420 jetzt
gerade es kommt es kamen schon drei lkw
ich bis jetzt normal ist für einen
normalen tag ein halber lkw bis einer
maximalen der weihnachtszeit also das
geht schon richtig ab meinte auch dass
das personal die hüften ist seit januar
dass das einst die ware einfach rein
geht und gar nicht gelagert werden kann
das gehen just in time direkt durch und
ich muss sagen wir haben es auch gesehen
mit eigenen augen die haben da in
dreifacher besetzung gearbeitet im
supermarkt also wir gehen auch sonst
kaufen und glücklich gesehen
dreifacher besetzung also muss man auch
sagen leute ganz wichtig für uns jetzt
auch in deutschland ist dass wir einfach
auch solchen leuten mit zumindest
verständnis entgegen treten im besten
und normalfall noch mit respekt und
wertschätzung also die auf die
verletzten dass unsere versorgung
aufrecht halten also leute die im
supermarkt arbeiten nicht nur die ihr
den krankenhäusern arbeiten die haben
sowieso größte hochachtung verdient aber
auch solche leute die jetzt hier halt
wirklich hart arbeiten und mehr gas
geben müssen als sonst und die auch von
kunden angegangen werden und so also der
mitarbeiter meinte auch das so angetan
pfandautomaten schon ein ausraster
schieben wenn es mal drei sekunden nicht
vorwärts geht soweit die leute wirklich
gereizt sind und ja also es hat auf
jeden fall jetzt gerade in den tagen im
lebensmitteleinzelhandel zu arbeiten
schauen alle von euch da draußen die das
machen
und ja wir fahren jetzt weiter zu aldi
einziger stein auf dem brötchen bis
kuchen dürften besonders solchen android
sind ziemlich heftig
g2 süßigkeiten sind da aber bis jetzt
hat was man sich andere rein
es liegen uns legen die auch einfach die
priorität so in der nachfrage halt nicht
auf frische ware jetzt muss aber eine
sache sagen also ganze ganzen
hamsterkäufe die apokalypse und die
massenpanik die in deutschland
vorherrscht ist für mich okay
womit ich ein problem habe ist eine
umstellung apple krumme dinger aus
deutschland nicht mehr verkauft werden
aus der punkt wo ich sage die
[Musik]
gehwegplatten reiniger ist darum herum
gefragt
pauli
muster eingeführt
in einer überaus großen computer- und
auch mit der prüfstelle produkte
toilettenpapier
ich glaube ich bin nicht mal ausgepackt
sind das kann alles ein denker wie heute
lernen diese sei aber dass leute fleisch
fleisch hat es dann gleich in der 3
dann endlich ist es dr
kleine blattsalate
er ist besitzen sind
da
seine heringsfilets
sie sind
nordseekrabben
oh mein gott ich hoffe dass wir das
sehen am wörthersee man gesehen mit
schweinefleisch konserven gerichtete
alle weg aber sowas ist da sowieso pizza
ist der salami crash erlebt ist als ich
so schon viel länger muss man nicht
verstehen
ich muss mit ausrücken
so jetzt immer auf dem gelände von aldi
runter und ich muss sagen
erwartungsgemäss wie es gedacht habe ist
es beim aldi tatsächlich im schlimmsten
maximal also all die er war wirklich
immer noch immer noch da also es ist
längst nicht so leute und ich hoffe das
ja den eindruck vermittelt und nicht mit
diesem video das man sich sorgen um die
lebensmittelversorgung machen müsse das
muss man nämlich nicht ja einzige was in
allen drei märkten nicht der fall war
gut mal die bisschen extremer aber die
anderen beiden war es höchstens mal so
dass scheuch das lieblingsprodukt was
man zum check der öfter kauft jetzt
gerade nicht da als was man aber kurz
festhalten muss in allen drei
supermärkten in denen jetzt war dass
sein klub habe hier echt nicht aber aber
zäh war gab es zumindest naja kann man
einfach zu variieren im notfall leute
alter studenten tipps halbieren
aber ganz wichtig leute ich will auch
noch meine reichweite nutzen um das zu
sagen heute in den kommenden tagen
großveranstaltung vermeiden sollte klar
sein aber auch falls noch ein club oder
so was in eurer nähe auf hat geht nicht
hingeht vielleicht auch nicht in bars
trefft euch wenn überhaupt wenn dann im
kleinen kreis wenn überhaupt am besten
einfach mit der familie oder zu hause
bleiben so händewaschen jeden tag ganz
wichtig und kümmert euch um vielleicht
alten leute in eurer nachbarschaft fragt
nach ob ich den einkauf machen können
für die ob er den helfen könnt leute es
geht jetzt wirklich darum dass wir in
deutschland als ein land zusammenstehen
die italiener haben es schon vorgemacht
jetzt sind wir dran dass wir einfach
zusammenhalten aufeinander rücksicht
nehmen und dann schaffen wir es auch bin
ich mir sehr sicher gut auch durch diese
krise und das war soweit mein eindruck
leute gerne eure meinung oder aktuellen
gedanken alles was ich im kopf und in
die kommentare rein ich mir die genau im
blick behalten da können wir uns ein
bisschen unterhalten
ich meine da schon raus findet an max
und eine beschreibung verlinkt und
bleibt gesund bleibt zu hause und schaut
rein